remember Harry Potter rictusempra no no
not that Harry Potter I'm talking about
the Harry Potter that navigated through
the world of wizards and witches to save
his family
no not that Harry Potter I'm talking
about Harry Potter ginger from troll yes
of course
yes Harry Potter jr. don't you remember
from the 1986 movie troll oh it's my
favorite Harry Potter jr. the best thing
I've heard in years has happened someone
made the character Harry Potter junior
16 years before the Harry Potter series
from JK Rowling JK Rowling plagiarized
the Harry Potter jr. character played by
Noah Hathaway in the troll movie my
favorite series of all time and I can't
believe more people are not talking
about this I am so disappointed in JK my
favorite anime character of all time for
not for disrespecting copyright law now
the creator of troll has decided to make
another movie because technically they
own their right to the name Harry Potter
jr. by copyright law they were burned
the movie is going to be called troll
the right of Harry Potter jr. and I for
one can't wait to see the real Harry
Potter in action again thank God now
Warner Brothers have realized they made
a statement about this the coming of
this film we will vigorously defend our
intellectual property rights and
challenge any unlawful attempt to
capitalize on the extraordinary success
of the Harry Potter franchise as we told
filmmakers years ago can you taste the
soft I feel like it's coming through the
screening I haven't seen troll Harry
Potter jr. expected to have a little
trouble getting adjusted in his new
neighborhood
troll you know I think I'm going to pass
the movie I have seen however which I
actually don't know if it has any
correlation to this movie it's troll 2
just so we can get excited for the new
troll movie the rights of Harry Potter
jr. what a troll by the way let's go
through troll 2 and see what we can
expect
who are they grandpa cruel deformed
forest dwellers party creatures spiteful
and impotent vengeful and evil goblins
he let start up with a granddad telling
a story to hit their grandson eh but he
doesn't call them trolls he calls them
anything but rose cruel deformed forest
dwellers just call them trolls please
English world in evil conferences what
do you mean goblin that's the point
goblins don't need to justify their
cruel acts although it's it's right
movie this neighbors talking about
goblins oh oh it's full - ok I thought
it was watching goblin - for a minute
huh that's a terrible film no one-on-one
sex it
Baldwin acting 101 right there
Oh goblins so basically the family
decides to go on a summer holiday
everything is lovely
everything is name a good old American
lame
[Music]
meanwhile on the way grandpa's trying to
give hints you have to make them go back
grandpa is dead by now but he's still
leaving hints for you to leave and we
have 30 seconds to come up with some way
to stop them oh wow I swear time froze
there a while they're not just hopefully
shake him everything could they not have
redone that take we're winning brain
dead go where did he go
never you had 30 seconds listen to your
granddad they're gonna eat the troll go
you look like you're about to molest
your family dude what are you what is he
gonna enter yeah not nipa just pee on
his family all right
see this guy in blue car best [ __ ]
character it's acting that I've ever
even seen before because it's so good
its world-renowned I'll take care of him
let me thank these lady from the troll
sorry Goblin there's one of them that
looks super freaky I don't know which
one it is
they're nice oh my god what let me give
you some advice to make yours oh [ __ ]
get out a table doesn't like to be
called for you're going to be in a lot
of trouble
got'em oh [ __ ]
and remember wear a condom
alright so they run into a church this
is my oh but it's the house of a witch
and this is where the big blue go a blue
shirt guy he's acting really shine I
[Music]
can't I can't bone what so much fun
oh my god what's happening I can't move
I cannot move
why oh my god what is happening to her
and why can't I move that damn I feel
awful read the prompt and then why can I
move that there must be a logical reason
today they come to you they're eating
her and then follows the famous oh so
beautiful line oscar-worthy they're
eating her and they're going to eat me
oh my god
[Applause]
oh my god no best spell don't like this
place not one bit
yeah I could only pee on my family once
it wasn't that great even our Kelly made
it like way better than idiot
Owen sure what are the girls from around
here go at night also notice notice that
the town is called nila Bock which I
think it's a nice little touch because
listen to this nilbog backwards its top
leg oh my god how did he not see that oh
my god he became a flag I don't believe
it
this is incredible and now the genius
child discovers the secret good luck
good luck are you there carbon exactly
nilbog
down
yeah you can probably recover from that
I don't see a problem what's wrong what
you stopped the time comes you like to
wake and throw the bottle I'll create
some confusion with fish right
how would either in here how is he alive
now I don't get it what troll also has
the best sex scene of all time
undisputable better than the room so the
which became attracted man yeah and she
squeezes her way into one of the men but
for some reason we have to do it heat it
up there's corn in this thing I don't I
don't know about the whole corn thing to
be honest I'm pretty sure they're just
throwing popcorn at set what the [ __ ]
was that
this guy looks this light guy looks like
a nice guy
if I ever see someone come up to me with
a smile like that I'd be boy can I help
you boy please please help me with
anything you want
can I help you coffee
yeah it really looks like he could use
some coffee this is me when I want
coffee yes there's no coffee here in
nilbog it's the devil's drink eggs I
guess I'll go for the second-best then
if he doesn't have any coffee how about
some eggs please I could really use some
eggs bacon how about some bacon day
we're vegetarians here in your bog I'm
not going to show that in Kazan want to
spoil the entire movie I think you guys
die if you haven't seen it it's a great
movie to watch with some friends I'm
sure there's a drinking game for it as
well and now of course more than
anything you feel the hype the strong
hype for troll the rise of Harry Potter
to me I can't wait it's going to be the
greatest movie of all time and finally
we see Harry Potter for what he really
is the none of this [ __ ] [ __ ]
whatever his name is
okay you know what I don't know what JK
Rowling has to say about this she hasn't
really made a statement yet but I weigh
what I imagine her first reaction to be
leave like if you enjoyed this video and
thank you guys so much for watching let
me know if you're excited for Harry
Potter jr. the rise of the Goblin give
whatever the [ __ ] it's called tweet this
video - JK Rowling and it's always
sister Pfister